what's your relationship like now with
Martin Scorsese I don't know not you
drop because because I know there was
stuff about you guys in the past but
Cape Fear is like one of my favorite
movies so good you know I had Marty you
know it's got he's New York site and so
you've gotta get in his way in order to
get to the sidered so he wasn't gonna
cast me as a painter so I think it was
Jeffrey Katzenberg that put me in that
and he said well it's only a 15-minute
film oh I'll go that way
and I had a ball doing life lessons I
mean just a ball
oh he did I just stayed up with Chuck
finally all night paint it and then when
they come in the morning to shoot Kyle
he would get pissed off because he's a
painter
what's his stop what's his action [ __ ]
this isn't afraid if I'll be done in the
bar you know so but Cape Fear they were
thinking of Dennis Quaid and I wasn't on
the list and I was in New York shooting
with Streisand on Prince of tides now
Marty only knew me as a big fat painter
that's really all the way he knew me
yeah
so I said to Billy Cross I said let's
put her a black suit so I go to this
casino party they are gonna have after
the showing unless you stand against the
wall like we're two lawyers outside the
thing watching and see what happens
pretty soon Marty walked by he looked he
double looked and he came back over to
me and say he's in it and that Nick
I said yes Marty Nick he said uh-huh
wait a minute I want to get my man wait
right here please
so I waited turn then walked over the
shyest man in the world um who is just
naturally that way
and bouncing oh and Marty said well
where are you gonna be tomorrow 12:00 I
said well I'm saying right around the
corner the-- their hotel they're right
around the corner from your office he
said could you be up my office said
12:00 and I said sure sure I'll be there
so I just put some glasses on and I went
over there Bob was there and after about
two minutes I said well you know I don't
really need these glasses and Bob's and
that's how I got the wrong that's
amazing yeah you're not seen as like an
attorney not not that you don't look
like you could be an attorney but again
you more of a bruiser
yeah 48 hours you would play these
aggressive guys you know we know people
just don't look at you and think
litigation